Although Albert Einstein's intelligence far
exceeded the average, his brain was, intriguingly,
smaller than the average man's.
A typical adult male brain weighs around 3
pounds (1,400 g)
Einstein’s weighed 2.64 pounds (1,197 g)
While smaller overall, a crucial section of
his brain was 15% wider than average.
The inferior parietal lobe is the region of
the brain associated with visual and spatial
reasoning.
This brain area would have been crucial to
coming up with Einstein’s famous theory
of general relativity, which describes how
a massive object can bend space-time around
it, much like how planets move in a curved
path around the sun.
In 1999, a team at Canada’s McMaster University
led by neuroscientist Sandra Witelson discovered
his parietal lobe was wider than normal because
it lacked a groove found in normal brains.
The Sylvian fissure, also known as the lateral
sulcus, usually separates the frontal and
parietal lobes from the temporal lobe.
However, in Einstein’s brain, this big crevice
was largely absent; the rear end was shorter
or truncated.
It did not extend as far into the parietal
lobe as it does in most people's brains.
This expanded Einstein’s parietal lobe,
making it wider than normal.
When Einstein died in 1955 at a New Jersey
hospital, the pathologist who performed the
autopsy removed his brain and kept it for
himself.
Dr. Thomas Harvey later convinced Einstein’s
son to allow him to keep it for research.
These labels were added by Harvey.
He cut Einstein’s brain into 240 blocks
and stored them in a cardboard box in his
office in a mason jar and in a cookie jar
preserved in gelatinous material.
Dr. Harvey procrastinated and never actually
published any research.
He did create 2,400 slides containing thin
sections of Einstein’s brain tissue to be
examined under a microscope and sent them
off to other scientists who revealed fascinating
insights.
In 2001, Dr. Dahlia Zaidel of the University
of California, Los Angeles, examined two slices
of Einstein’s brain containing the hippocampus,
which plays a crucial role in learning and
memory.
She found that the neurons on the left side
of Einstein's hippocampus were larger than
those on the right.
The left hemisphere is primarily responsible
for logical thinking, analytical processing,
and mathematical abilities.
Larger neurons in the left hippocampus suggested
stronger nerve cell connections between the
hippocampus and the neocortex, which is the
command center of the brain involved in high-level
thinking.
In addition to the asymmetry in Einstein's
hippocampus, researchers also found that the
bundle of nerve fibers connecting the two
hemispheres of his brain called the corpus
callosum was thicker than average.
In 2013, researchers from China and the US
found that Einstein's corpus callosum, denoted
in red, was thicker than those in the control
group of elderly men denoted in blue, and
also thicker than most of those in the younger
control group of men 24 to 30 years old, denoted
in green.
This increased thickness likely facilitated
better communication between the left and
right hemispheres, contributing to Einstein's
exceptional cognitive abilities.
It can be likened to a wider bridge between
two cities, enabling faster transportation
of people and goods and improved overall connectivity.
Dr. Harvey also sent off four slices of Einstein’s
brain in a mayonnaise jar to neuroscientist
Marian Diamond of the University of California
Berkeley
Her study, published in 1985, concluded that
Einstein’s brain had more support cells
than average.
These red and blue structures are called glial
cells - aptly named from the Greek word 'glee-ull',
meaning 'glue'.
They play a critical role in nourishing and
protecting the neurons.
Additional protection might have allowed his
neurons to function more effectively.
Remarkably, Einstein’s brain didn’t show
any signs of aging.
Even at the age of 76, his brain had no traces
of lipofuscin, the fine yellow-brown pigment
granules associated with "wear and tear" in
the human brain, similar to how an old car
might accumulate rust over time.
It’s believed Einstein was born this way
rather than being influenced by environmental
factors.
But it doesn’t mean our brains can’t change.
Dr. Diamond was the first to show that the
brain can change and improve at ANY age.
Her work with rats demonstrated that those
who played with mazes, ladders, wheels, and
their companions had larger brain cells and
a greater amount of glial cells compared to
rats that were kept isolated with no toys.
The implication is that all animals, including
humans, benefit from an enriched environment,
and impoverished environments can lower the
capacity to learn.
This is now called plasticity of the brain.
And it has powerful implications for what
we’re capable of achieving.
According to Einstein’s wishes, his body
was cremated, and his ashes were scattered
in a secret spot by the Delaware River.
He didn’t want his body to be worshipped.
But Einstein’s biographer said that, “He
had insisted his brain be used for research…”
Even after nearly 70 years, Einstein’s brain
still has so much to teach the world.
Just like Einstein's brain, our own genetic
makeup holds secrets about who we are.
I was excited to partner with MyHeritage,
the leading DNA service that helps discover
your origins.
I even found new relatives based on my shared
DNA.
MyHeritage showed me 97 people I matched with
and I’m starting to reach out to them to
build my family tree.
If you’re curious about your ancestry, you
can order a kit with my custom link in the
description.
And use my code: NEWSTHINK for free shipping.
You’ll also get a 30-day FREE trial of MyHeritage’s
best subscription for family history research
and a 50% discount if you decide to continue.
MyHeritage will never sell or license your
genetic data.
You are the sole owner of your DNA data.
Thanks for watching.
For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.